by a vote of nine
to two janelle you are evicted from the
big brother house
janelle you're not sitting like someone
who's very happy like there's a little
lean happening here
what's your mood right now oh i'm
actually very happy
um i'm excited i know i know that it's
shocking
i've played this game so many times i
feel really great about everything
and i'm just like glad i came back for
another all-stars
and i'm pleasantly happy that i'm going
home to see my family
okay yeah i i totally get that the
problem is the fans are devastated
i understand that and i do feel bad i
you know i came back on this season for
the fans for the show just to have a
little fun
i feel like yes i definitely let them
down i'm
disappointed i couldn't last further you
know
but it is what it is well i don't think
the fans feel like you let them down i
mean that's that's
awesome for you to say that i think you
know there's there's an element of shock
you know when i talked to you before
this i didn't expect you to
be out of the house this soon are you
surprised that you're sitting here right
now
no not at all uh initially
when they asked me to do all-stars i was
hesitant because i know
how fast people gunned for me to get out
of the house it's usually
immediate so that was my hesitation
to even come back so i was like well you
know it's
difficult to survive with week after
week when they're they gun for you
and target you so you're a legend julie
chen said that you're a big brother
legend uh what would you say
to the fans what's your message to them
i'm so sorry
um i didn't make it further i'm super
grateful
for another experience another all-star
season
and i absolutely love my fans so much
and if they can please be nice to nicole
anthony
when we talked a few weeks ago you told
me that you wanted to play
the direct quote is super cutthroat and
go out with a bang
do you think you did that well i didn't
get a chance to get power so
obviously like there would have been two
really big players up if i had one hoh
but it didn't happen
so did i go out with a bang absolutely
always what do you think was harder your
first all-stars or
this one my first all-stars was way
harder that was
an initial gunning for me day one
targeting me day one
and the only thing that kept me alive in
the house in my old all-star season was
competition wins and my alliance winning
competitions
so you mentioned caser you see him you
know it's been all these years
did memories come flooding back right
away they do
because we just hang out in the house
and live together and he just
remembers everything about me you know
my
desire for sugar and sweets and then
complaining that i'm
disgusting and fat after i eat it
[Laughter]
he's just like he knows me so well he's
like
literally one of my best friends so he
just knows what it's like to be in the
house with me
and memories always do come back well do
you think if he hadn't been in the house
you would have had a better chance in
all this
yeah probably yeah i mean yeah
definitely
i mean if it were just me i could have
easily gotten into
whatever alliance i needed to there was
definitely a thing where
perhaps some people wanted to work with
me but maybe they didn't want to work
with case or kind of thing
initially i wanted to work with tyler
really bad that would have been my first
pick to do something with and go to him
with a potential alliance but i couldn't
it's hard
you know it's hard to play as a pair
what was it like emotionally to be
on the block with him again history kind
of repeated itself
i've never left on the block with caser
he's always left before me
so and i but i knew this time it's
different because
of my history and what i've done in the
game i was actually
okay with it because i did want to give
caser a chance to experience
playing without me and see how well he
does
right it's the first time ever that he's
he's going to be in the house
playing the game without you uh how do
you think he's gonna do how will the
game go and how will he do in there
i think he'll do all right i mean
obviously he's still a big
huge target because he knows the
alliance in the house
he will absolutely go after those guys
you know it all comes down to
who wins power if one of the people not
in that alliance wins power i think
there's a very good chance that they do
go after the alliance
will you watch absolutely i'm so yeah
i watch every episode every season i've
never missed it i'm still
even though i've played i'm still a huge
huge fan you did
actually get two votes uh you got a vote
from enzo and vote from danny
um julie was shocked by the danny bow
what was your reaction to that
i don't know what went on with the votes
why you know the other ones i haven't
seen anything i don't know why they
didn't vote for me
um it's whatever i mean
great two votes great i didn't want to
go unanimous again so
that's great so memphis was working with
the other side of the house
this entire time what did you think of
that i'm very i was very surprised
i'm very impressed with his game play
you know i'm excited to see what he can
do in the game
and i'm excited to see if he can win is
there a part of you or a lot of you that
wants to warn caser
oh my gosh i'm so worried for caser
because we tell memphis everything
like everything what would you say to
him if you could
don't trust memphis i want to talk to
you about nicole you have this
relationship with each other
things got rocky in the house for you
too to say the least
tell me how you really feel about her at
this point unfortunately
we played the amazing race together and
there are situations and scenarios
and gameplay that she did where i saw
something in her that i i didn't trust
her because she backstabbed someone
so when i saw her in the house i was
like cool like we've got
this little whatever past friendship
but you know i it's hard for me to
i never trusted her and she needs a lot
of like
she's very insecure so i and i knew that
going in there they have to
constantly tell her she's good she's
good she's good i just couldn't keep up
with it honestly in the house
and she had such an obvious alliance to
me it was like
at this point she knows i don't like her
so
it sounds uh draining for you mhm
you're putting that simply i don't like
her how much do you dislike her how
would you describe
the way that you feel about her her
whining and her voice
is insufferable to me i absolutely hate
hearing her voice
what did you think of her goodbye
message to you she told you
don't come to my wedding i wasn't going
to come anyway i actually have a
you know a cheer competition with my
daughters that weekend so
wasn't going to come anyway i still will
keep it classy and i'm gonna send him a
nice gift
something off the registry you know i
don't know maybe yeah we'll see
if you could say anything to her right
now what would you say
stop crying be suffer quit being a [ __ ]
and sorry
that's it that's all i have to say about
that there's some people where
you know if you think to yourself they
could do a couple things maybe your
relationship with them could be better a
couple changes but for you and her is it
just gone
i will not have a relationship with
nicole franzelle
uh once this season is wrapped i have no
desire to
maintain that sort of relationship with
her
and i don't i've never trusted her and
honestly
she yeah i just i don't like her
gameplay that's it
was this season the nail in the coffin
on that yeah pretty much
you said that you mentioned what your
downfall uh you kind of felt like
was anything specific you would have
done differently
during these these last days i wish i
could have
you know reeled caser in a little better
he
gets too excited and you know really
likes to go for it
it's great to have that passion in the
game but unfortunately we didn't win
power
so we just look like freaking idiots
because
he was like literally telling everyone
in the house that we're putting up
cody and i'm just like this is not good
this is not not good for me i knew it
was not good for me
because i'm tied with caser and i'm
much bigger of a threat so i knew last
week
when he was giggling and laughing that
he wanted to blow up the house i was
like
i'm gonna be on the block next week
defend it with power which
sucks what was your strategy knowing
that that was gonna happen
what do i do the guy's walking i mean he
wants to
do that and i have to play with him i'm
tied to him no matter what
what can i do that's what he wants to do
he's targeting the other side
i feel like you're a person who doesn't
like to look like an idiot now
no i don't and i've tried to tell him
like
you need to chill out on this you need
to stop
telling everyone in the house what you
want to do because
i'm tied to you reaction to enzo being
the new hoh how do you think he'll do
what do you think he'll do
i'm super excited for him but i feel
like
he's not going to take a crack at that
alliance because he thinks he's in the
alliance
can i make a prediction on nominations i
was going to say
yes absolutely so you're caser and david
oh you know what what i hope he does is
i hope he puts up nicole
and ian not that nicole would leave but
i know in the past i've talked with enzo
and
we've kind of talked a little strategy
that's like an easy nomination
because they're both winners he could do
that he i mean
i hope he does that who are you rooting
for in the end
and who do you hope follows you out the
door next i am rooting for
obviously caser i would love for bailey
to do well
but if enzo can win this game i would be
so so happy you know he's a single dad
he's a nice guy
i hope he wins janelle you're a legend
could we see you play this game a fifth
time
lord i think no um if there were a
shortened version of 30 days like a you
know a winter package or a little
whatever a 30 day thing yes sign me up
but like
i can't do this again come back for
another you know
long period in the summer it's just i've
got my business and my family i'm
i feel like i'm good on that